on plonge littéralement dans nos
archives pour se retrouver en 1995
cette année là dans un reportage on
allait à la rencontre d'inuits qui
pratiquer une activité ancestrale la
pêche aux moules sous la banquise
pas
[Musique]
un soir de pleine lune sur le petit
village de cagnes et souillac
même les aboiements d'un chien ne
viennent pas troubler la quiétude des
lieux
[Musique]
gagner 6 watts et un petit village inuit
de 400 habitants au nord du 60e
parallèle et à une centaine de
kilomètres du cercle arctique
yannick una look pêche les moules depuis
sa tendre enfance
les jeunes comme yannick on pose la
moitié de la population du village
et quand ils ne sont pas à l'école on
les retrouve la plupart du temps à la
pêche ou à la chasse c'est son
grand-père à tata dans la langue inuit
qui lui enseigne et tous les rudiments
de la cueillette des moules sous la
glace
des meilleurs endroits pour la pêche aux
moules sont situés près de l'embouchure
de la baie de ouakam
cette baisse étant sur une quinzaine de
kilomètres et est un site favorable pour
la pêche on y retrouve entre autres
l'ongle de l'arctique une espèce très
prisée par les amateurs de poissons et
c'est aussi le long de ses côtes que
l'isi nous équiper les moules à la
pleine lune la marée descend encore plus
que d'habitude ce qui laisse un peu plus
d espace sous la glace pour la
cueillette des moules la glace qui
recouvre le trou est mince et en
creusant yani et son grand père constate
que la marine n'a pas encore atteint son
niveau le plus bas
il faut donc respecter l'horaire des
marées et attendre plus avant que l'eau
se soit retirée complètement
ils doivent se hâter qu'elle bénéficie
d'environ 90 minutes pour ramasser les
moules
[Musique]
l'environnement est saisissant un peu
comme si on était dans une caverne
enfouis sous des tonnes de roche
la lumière se faufile par des fissures
dans la glace donne des teintes colorées
ou du four néanmoins y aller d'une
dernière vérification de la condition de
la glace avant d'entreprendre la pêche
[Musique]
il ne faut pas compter sur deux là parce
que si entre eux je dormais il faut
qu'on ne passe jamais créé de pour le
métier enfants très dangereux ici dans
les régions de cagnes issus du wac
ce sont les moules bleues qui
envahissent le fond des eaux les moules
s'accroche au fond rocheux ou sablonneux
il y occupe principalement les zones
soumises à l'action démarré encore une
fois aujourd'hui elles tapissent les
roches sur le sol yanni son grand-père
peuvent l'y cueillir plus facilement
ils ont l'embarras du choix à l'hiver
les moussons plus grosse
ce qui fait que les innu il préfère les
ramasser durant la saison froide dans
toute la région de cagnes et souillac
est très bonne pour amasser des moules
on peut aller n'importe où dans la baie
mais c'est ici le meilleur villages des
environs pour les moules après environ
une heure de pêche yannis on grimpait
ont rempli un sac de moules chacun
tandis que le mari commence à remonter
les pêcheurs pu remonter à la surface
l'occasion de faire un peu d'exercice
après une pêche éreintante ya ni son
grand-père vont profiter du soleil
radieux déguster le fruit de leur labeur
bienvenus pourquoi on tue à pêcher avec
ton grand père comme ça parce que des
fois mon grand-père besoin d'elle et
j'aime j'aime facilement de l'oci ça
fait longtemps que j'ai pas s'arrêter
[Musique]
les jeunes ont reçu un héritage des
aînés un présent qui leur est cher la
liberté de vivre au gré du temps dans la
pure tradition des habitants du grand
nord à la prochaine pleine lune gagner
son grand père vont revenir sur la côte
juste au cas où la classerais encore
assez bonne pour une autre pêche aux
moules
c'est un peu cela la vie nuit au nord du
60e parallèle
[Musique]